on va essayer de vous montrer ce qui a
eu des images très drôle aussi à la
télévision bien sûr qu'ils sont passés
je voudrais aussi avoir votre ressenti
sur ce qui s'est passé autour de la
table parce que je pense que c'est ce
que veulent savoir aussi les
téléspectateurs
on a une relation privilégiée avec eux
on les a tous les soirs avec nous en
direct et c'est vrai qu'on on est une
grande famille doucement mon poste que
soient les les gens chez eux les gens
ici les gens autour de la table donc je
pense qu'ils ont envie de savoir où vous
étiez comment vous avez ressenti
également les choses vendredi soir
julien merci d'être là mon julien série
mercy mercier moi j'suis ampoules
l'applaudir dans ce groupe où l'on peut
dire merci d'être là c'est très heureux
de vous retrouver mon jugement - jugée
comme on dit ça va mais ça va pas du
tout à ça on a envie d'être là enfin
c'est ce qu'on vous en parle avec gildas
tout à l'heure avant de démarrer c'est à
dire que c'est la csu très difficile
pour nous parce qu'on en a envie d'être
là franchement c'est l'amour et j'aurais
pété bien sûr n'avait pas fait
l'émission parce qu'à un moment donné on
a l'impression de leur donner raison
d'être loin de tout ça et on n'a pas non
plus envie de se déguiser tout ça mais
voilà je trouve vachement bien vous ayez
pris la décision tout à l'heure de faire
cette émission et qu'on soit là il
resterait des missions différentes mais
on est là on en parle on va en parler à
notre façon il ya détermination d'en
parler les chaînes info parle d'une
façon nous on va en parler de façon tpm
paix mais on n'est pas exclu tout ça au
contraire on est là j'ai la chair de
poule d'avoir où tout ce que j'ai vu là
et on va le faire jusqu'au bout mais
c'est bien faire et on a envie aussi
il faut il faut divertir les gens c'est
vrai que voilà je sais c'est important
et bien sûr on sent moins important dans
notre émission quand on voit tout ce qui
se passe mais aussi voilà ya peut-être
des gens si tu as envie de se changer
les idées mais on peut pas complètement
déconnecté de ce qui se passe donc
forcément peut pas faire une émission
complètement normal on va retrouver bien
sûr bertrand il y aura camille également
leur a même d'eric vous verrez qui
viendra nous voir en fin d'émission
cabon mercredi je vous avez vous appelé
bertrand chamerois 1 celui qui revient
de new york pour matthieu delormeau qui
est la mère si bas que
tam au sérieux bon alors je fais tout le
tour et peu après vous nous raconterez
parce que n 1 qui était juste à côté ont
plus et jean luc lemoine un jean luc et
là ce soir avec nous merci mon ami jean
michel maire etc avec nous thierry
moreau gilles verdez isabelle morini
bosc
enora malagré est donc aujourd'hui que
le moine alors j'aimerais avoir un petit
mot de chacun dont vous vous étiez comme
vous l'a dit un julien bojan lui que
vous étiez sur scène un vendredi soir
oui oui j'étais sur scène à l'apollo
théâtre qui se trouve à république
adagio pas donc de désalement à deux pas
puisque ça a tiré à 200 mètres du
théâtre
mais c'est vrai que c'était au début
c'était l'incompréhension moi j'ai fini
mon spectacle à 21h20 on m'a prévenu que
dix y avait des tirs dans la rue des
gens revenaient en courant dans le
théâtre
honnêtement j'ai cru que c'était un
règlement de compte c'est pas pour dire
qu'il n'avait pas peur d'un règlement de
mots mais on disait
j'espère que cette des tirs comme ça
qu'ils n'ont touché personne et puis
d'un seul coup on sort et puis on
m'avait dit que des gens de du public
était traumatisée était en pleurs dans
l'eau j'ai été les voir sur coup un
deuxième mouvement de foule des gens qui
courent et qui se réfugient dans le
théâtre
et là on a compris que c'était grave qui
se passait quelque chose même baissé le
rideau on s'est retrouvé avec le public
du spectacle suivant y avait 500
personnes qui étaient dans le théâtre et
à la compréhension et après les premiers
chiffres qui tombent on nous dit qu'à
sept morts on se dit que c'est déjà
c'est déjà hallucinant et criant et
d'après les chiffres qui tombent de plus
en plus et là c'est la stupéfaction et
surtout un sentiment d'impuissance et
d'incompréhension il paraît qu'il ya des
spectateurs qui vous en remercier
d'avoir fait un rappel oui enfin ça
c'était les gardiens c'est exotique mais
c'est vrai que c'est effrayant
on a une pensée pour toutes un ce qui
qui ont été vraiment touchée de plein
fouet et puis et puis aussi une pensée
pour ceux qui sont passés à côté et
c'est vrai que moi y'a des gens qui vont
dire heureusement que le spectacle a été
cinq minutes plus court sinon on était
en plein dans la fusillade alors
l'idée c'est pas du tout de dire quelque
chose d'héroïque la danse et c'est bien
sûr la chance c'est la chance mais c'est
quelque chose qui devrait pas arriver de
toute façon et c'est quelque chose qui
est absolument
enfin jeudi des banalités mais jean luc
est ce que vous allez reprendre le
spectacle jeudi c'est une vraie question
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya une
appréhension je pense que même les gens
qui vont au théâtre vont avoir peur je
crois que les chiffres de fréquentation
baisse dans tous les théâtres mais je
des je dis moi j'y retourne
et comme la plupart des comédiens
pourquoi parce que même si à cinquante
personnes et où c'est pas grave on s'en
fout
l'idée c'est de se dire que l'on
n'oubliera jamais ça sera plus jamais
comme avant mais il faut continuer à
vivre
et s'il ya des gens qui sont là et bien
on sera là on sent mais je pense que il
faut qu'on continue à aller dans les
restaurants il faut qu'on continue à
vivre parce que sinon ils gagnent